And it looks at it. How much
trouble are we in? Legitimately?
I mean it's pretty bad already and it's
going to get, I think a lot, lot worse.
So it's not bad right now. Right here.
It's raining. It seems nice out. The heal.
I mean, how long ago were the fires?
Right, right. Got One back. He waited.
It was October. Yeah, it was rough.
But in all fairness had been evacuated
three times over the past 20 years. Yeah.
I know the fires in California fires
are kind of interesting in that, um,
they both seem like it's like the
future of the apocalypse. They're here,
but also it's so familiar from
like decades of wildfires. Um,
but you know,
there's scientific estimates that say
that they're going to get by the end of
the century, 64 times worse. What? Yeah.
I think that number's a little high
because that would mean more than half of
California burning every year. But,
um, I mean, it's going to get, yeah,
it'll get,
it'll get crazy.
And there's no way to avoid any of this
wildfire stuff. Well, I mean, you know,
if we don't raise the temperature
of the planet then, but is,
is that the only thing that's
causing wildfire? I mean,
like obviously if the temperature raises,
there's more brown dry leaves and grass
and stuff like that. But you know,
there's a, there's a lot of
preventative stuff you can do. I mean,
not building in certain areas. Like,
I mean it used to be, you know,
the Indians who lived here
before the white people came, um,
did a lot of controlled burning.
They like lived among fires. And, um,
I think that's like a probably
more responsible way to be.
But we've now built up the whole state
so that they're all these homes that we
don't want to burn their, all these
properties we don't want to burn.
And when you,
um,
when you like restrict the
ability of natural fires to burn,
that means that like more Tinder gets
built over time and then, you know,
at some point some thing lights
the match and it all burns. So,
I mean, you could, um, you
could do more controlled fire,
you could take more aggressive
action in terms of, um, you know,
like spraying foam and that kind of thing.
You could have a lot more firefighters,
but I was just talking to a guy yesterday,
I'm out here actually doing some
reporting on wildfires and, um,
who is saying that no,
Santa Ana powered wildfire has ever been
stopped by firefighters and he was like,
uh, environmental historian. Wow. Um,
it's like you can hope that
the winds redirect them,
but like the action of firefighters is
basically just spitting in the wind.
So the action is not to stop. It's a kind
of contain it. Yeah. As best they can.
Yeah. In minimize property
damage. Yeah. But you know,
it's hard because you have a lot more,
it's a lot easier to do that when, um,
you know, if the land was totally
raw, you'd be like, Oh, let's,
we'll just like try to direct
the fire in this direction.
But if the land is like full of homes
here, like, well, we, can't you,
have you ever seen it live?
Not In person one. Yeah.
One time we were filming fear factor
and we were a way up on the five,
like,
um,
probably I would say maybe 75 miles from
here and for a full hour driving about
50 miles an hour,
there was fire on the right hand
side of the road for a full hour.
I mean like Lord of the
rings end of the world,
like you waiting for Satan to come riding
on a burning Phoenix over the top of
the hill. It was crazy. I'd never
seen anything like it in my life.
That was the worst one I've ever seen.
But I think that was just
because of placement.
I think that this past one was actually
worse in terms of physical damage and
size. It's just, I didn't see it
the way I saw this one. Well, I,
the last year there were,
there were flames, like
hopping over the four oh five,
right? I mean, um, and that's, that's
really like crazy to me because, you know,
I'm a New Yorker.
I've lived my whole life in New
York and I just feel in my bones.
I now know it's sort of not true,
but like my inner emotional perspective
on the world is that I live in a
fortress. I don't live in nature. Like
I walked down on concrete streets.
I look up at steel buildings.
Nature can't come from me,
but when you see like fire straddling
the four or five, that's, you know,
this is a major metropolis
here. Um, and we're not safe.
We're certainly not totally safe. Um,
and that's like, for me, that's a major,
like a major revelation I've
had is that wherever you live,
no matter how defended
against nature you are,
climate change is teaching us that,
you know,
you still live within climate and when
it gets fucked up, it will fuck you up.
It will affect you in some
way. Yeah. There was, uh,
the both sides of the four oh five,
we're on fire last year,
last year or the year before that, one
of those. But it was insane. It was,
it's, it was hitting bel air. And
people are like, well this is this.
We've never seen this before.
I talked to a firefighter
once and this was years ago,
and he told me with the right wind,
it's a matter of time for a fire,
hits the top of La and burns all
the way to the ocean. And he goes,
and there's not gonna be anything
we could do about it. He goes,
if the right wind catches and a fire
starts at the top of Los Angeles,
it'll just go straight through la.
Look at this.
What does that from Jamie or five
fire. Yeah. Okay. Oh that's it.
That's the crazy video.
So this is bel air and the lefthand side.
And so these are people driving down
the four oh five looking at, you know,
the most insane site for a place that
has 30 million people or whatever.
La has to see the entire hillside
on fire and bel air up. To me,
Bella is really interesting cause
it's, you know, most climate impacts,
they hit the world's poorest
first and like the wildfires are,
they work in the reverse because
it's like people living in the hills,
those are the rich people. But it just
shows you like no matter how rich you are,
no matter how comforted by that wealth
you are like, you know, you might get hit.
Well the best example was
a point Dume yeah. And uh,
we were flying over it.
My friend, uh, Bill uh,
has a helicopter license and so we went
around the peak of point Dume it's crazy
because you know,
these are like $20 million estates,
these massive bluff side homes.
They thought they were living in the
peak of luxury overviewing the ocean and
like, wow, we're on top of the world. And
the fire just scorched it to the ground.
Like that's what it looks like
now. Yeah. That's so crazy.
Well it's really crazy because
you'd like the, they couldn't even,
because people have always said,
oh well they'll protect the rich
folks then in protect these ones.
They can't protect anybody
when it gets this crazy. Yeah.
I think they lost more than 600
homes in Malibu alone. Yeah. I mean,
and that's, I mean, yeah. And you think
about Miami beach going underwater. Well,
Miami beach is a weird one, right?
Because the ground is porous. Yeah. Yeah.
So it's inevitable to get out of there.
That's basically a sandbar that like some
developers and the 20th decided that,
oh, we can make this into a fake paradise.
Oh really? Yeah. I mean, there was, yeah,
it was, um, I mean la is kind of the same
way. Like nobody looking at La in 1850,
it would have said like, here's a
great place to build a city. Um,
but we did it anyway like America and
it's like imperial swagger was like, no,
we can create some paradise out of this
completely in his biteable land in both
places. And then, you know, it's
just a lesson that like, you know,
it's just a matter of time.
Well,
the most cocky people are the people
that have those houses on stilts,
on the water in Malibu.
I want,
is this going to work out for you?
Like this thing moves back and forth
over time, and it has forever. I mean,
if you think about like the long,
long sweep of human history,
most human settlements didn't
happen on the coast. Right?
Um, like people lived in,
maybe they live on a river,
maybe you'd have like a little community
on the river, but the, you know,
the last like 50 years, we, a hundred
years we built up, especially in America,
so much more on the coast. And that's
like, you know, really inviting disaster.
I mean, all of Houston, like all of
that is like, that was flood plain.
That like nature was like, you know, it
was swamp land. It was, and now it's,
you know,
new suburban developments made out of
concrete and that just means more and more
flooding.